you were like an unbelievably uh strong
woman i don't know if people know the
story but uh
you uh
her father you her father was not
involved in her life you raised her but
that's that's
by myself you know there was always uh
seal you know still was there from the
very beginning i know that like my
biological dad was not there no right
but and because by choice by that's what
i'm saying by your choice by both of our
choice yeah you said i want to have this
baby yeah don't worry about it yeah you
know if i want i'm taking the
responsibility i thought that was pretty
amazing and unusual right
i don't know for me everything was
unusual you know at the time because no
one around me why did you bring him beer
why did you bring him beer he's just
burping next time i come i will bring
you no beer
tums or something
that'll fix me if he's not coughing up
loogies he's burping and [ __ ]
himself because one thing i like to do
one thing i like to do
so anyway
what i was saying is you raised to
you have you're very independent and now
uh people know this you have four
children um beautiful children who
you've uh i think my boys are six three
i know they're 15 and 16. now how did
their friends feel about coming over
short
no no
i wasn't talking about their height
i was talking about their mother like if
you as a 15 year old boy
if uh my 15 year old friend's mother
looked like you
i remember a conversation we once had
because you're okay with nudity
i promise
when friends come over i put my top on
no but that you would they they had i
thought
underwear out though that might be
obvious yeah but i will wear a hedgehog
no but that's the thing that was a
discussion yeah of course it was a
discussion with my kids of course they
say mom when someone comes over and i'm
like of course i will be wearing
something when someone comes over but
they had to tell you that
no but we talked about it like as if i
was not going to wear anything i didn't
say to my mom you my friend jeff's
coming over put a top on i never said
that i know and most
parents are different than i am i was
brought up very freely and you know i
don't think there is anything wrong with
that i don't run around nude outside i'm
totally minding my own business in my
own backyard with my own offspring you
know if someone else comes i put my
clothes on that's nice
i speak five languages all i can say is
do you speak that language
i just can't imagine alex can you
imagine like hanging out at home and
having mom or dad just naked in the
backyard no but she's not really
when your kids are home no problem those
are my kids
they came out of me they should be able
to handle it
have you said that to them
i don't have to when they said after
they say uh mommy where did i come from
you showed them the hedgehog
they've seen videos
you know i went to the pawn shop i love
the birth of their own birth yeah really
you show them videos of you their own
birth i went to a pawn shop the other
day
thanks for asking amy i also grew up in
a very nude household like my like to
this day like my family still walks
around naked like we're just free like
that hippie hippies at heart
it's i mean there's nothing weird about
that but you know what my mom to put
clothes on too
all right caroline put your pants on and
turn the mic off okay that's like see
they don't even put your butts okay but
see they don't even have to ask me i
know to put my clothes on if someone
else comes you're amazing that way
um i'm amazing that way you didn't even
have to tell me i just did something
[Laughter]
speaking of nudity you brought me but
what's wrong with it though
nothing nothing in your case i'm going
to be in las vegas i'm going to be in
las vegas march 28th through april 3rd
i'm going to be there which includes the
first and you're welcome to come heidi
april 1st is the one of the days that
i'm there and on that day i'm giving
away 72
million dollars okay i think it's i
think it's just a difference in opinion
and how comfortable you are depending on
the person like i know
even with
breastfeeding my kids i was
uncomfortable doing it in public or
without like a shield whereas some
people
are which is fine well your daughter's
seven
what no
no but i mean even with that where
you're supposed to feel fine
breastfeeding your kid i was not
comfortable with that so i think it's
just a difference in opinion and a
difference in people right i would just
always gauge you can gauge people if
some people are uncomfortable i don't
want to make anyone uncomfortable you
like making people uncomfortable you you
enjoy that like you know i mean but not
the kids and i would have like a little
you know like a little blankie that i
would put over the baby when i was
breastfeeding and i was breastfeeding
all four of them for eight months each
so it's like it's impo how can you like
not do it now
[Music]